The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation, or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Ladies and gentlemen,
welcome to
lecture number 12.
In this lecture, I would like
to discuss with you solution
methods for eigenproblems.
This is a very large field,
and all I can do really in
this lecture is to give you or
discuss this you a few of the
solution methods that
we are using in
finite element analysis.
So it will be a very brief
introduction, a brief survey
of the methods of solution that
we're using for finite
element eigenvalue problems.
The generalized eigenvalue
problem, K phi equals lambda M
phi, is a problem that we
encountered in the multiple
position analysis.
Please recognize that I'm
calling lambda here, the
eigenvalue, which was our omega
squared in the last lecture.
This is really the eigenproblems
that we are
primarily addressing ourselves
to finite element analysis.
The standard eigenproblems
problem here, EVP stands for
eigenproblem, has M equal
to the identity matrix.
So when we're talking about
solution methods of this
problem, we're really also talk
about solution methods of
this problem.
If we have, in a [? multiple ?]
position
analysis, non-proportional
damping, then we would have to
solve this eigenproblem, which
is a quadratic eigenproblem.
I will not address myself to the
solution of this problem,
so in what follow, we are
talking about a solution of
this problem, and of course, the
solution of this problem
also, when M is equal to
the identity matrix.
In particular, we are interested
in the solution of
large eigenvalue problems when
N, is say, greater than 500.
N, of course, being the order of
K and M, and with the half
bandwidth, I should say,
being greater than 60.
The number of eigenvalues that
we will be looking for, that
we want to calculate, are say,
1 to 1/3 of N. 1/3 of N is
already large number
of eigenvalues.
Generally, we are talking about
1 to and at most, 100
for large eigenproblems.
When we have a small eigenvalue
problem, in other
words, N being small, say 50
or 100, there are a large
number of different techniques
that can be used to solve this
eigenvalue problem, and it
really does not make that much
difference which technique
you are using.
The cost can still be quite
significant, but certainly,
when we're talking about very
large eigenproblems, N being
even larger than a 1,000 or
2,000, then it is of up most
concern to select a technique
that is very effective.
And I want to address myself
really now towards those
techniques that we feel are
very effectively used in
finite element analysis.
In dynamic analysis, of course,
with proportional
damping, this was the eigenvalue
problem that we
wanted to solve.
Now, if they are 0 frequencies
present, in other words, when
we have rigid body modes in the
system, then we can use
the following procedure to
basically getting rid of these
0 frequencies.
We simply add, on the left hand
side, a mu M phi, and on
the right hand side,
a mu M phi.
And taking these two together,
we are getting this
coefficient matrix, and
a new lambda value.
That lambda value now is omega
squared plus mu, where omega
squared is equal to
lambda minus mu.
What we have been doing here,
is basically, we have been
applying a shift.
In other words, if we were to
plot the characteristic
polynomial, giving us
the eigenvalues, the
characteristic polynomial of
course, being p of lambda
being determined K bar minus
lambda M, where K bar is equal
to K plus mu M.
If we plug this characteristic
polynomial, we will see this
curve here, schematically drawn,
of course, where the
omega squared values would start
here, in other words,
the lowest omega squared
value is, in fact, 0.
Whereas our lambda value
now starts right here.
This is the shift that
we [? imposed. ?]
So, basically, we now recognize
that we have all
eigenvalues being greater than
0, because this is our new
starting value.
All eigenvalues measured from
here are greater than 0, the
smallest one being mu,
namely when omega
squared is equal to 0.
And the larger ones
being here.
It is effective to perform such
a shift when we have 0
eigenvalues, in other words, to
operate on this eigenvalue,
rather than on that one, because
our techniques then
are very stable and effective,
and this shift here is, in
general, therefore performed.
So all we have to address
ourselves to then from now on,
is really, the solution of
eigenvalues and eigenvectors,
when all of the eigenvalues
are greater than 0.
If we start off with a problem
where we have a 0 frequency,
we apply the shift so that the
eigenvalues now of this
problem here are all
greater than 0.
In buckling analysis, we
have this eigenproblem.
We really did not talk about--
we did not really at all about
buckling analysis in the set
of lectures, but you might just
be interested in finding
out how would we solve for
these eigenvalues.
Well, here is the characteristic
polynomial.
The smallest lambda value, of
course, gives now a critical
load, that is the one e would
be interested in.
It is effective here,
to rewrite this
problem in this form.
All we do, is we are taking
the lambda value onto the
other side.
In other words, we
are dividing this
equation here by a lambda.
So that one of the lambda stands
on this side, and KG
phi on that side.
The resulting problem is this
one, where kappa is 1 over
lambda and we have now
here, is a K matrix.
K is positive definite, and now
it is more effective to
operate on this equation.
How do we obtain now
the largest kappa?
Because the largest kappa is the
one that we are interested
in, which corresponds to the
smallest lambda, the smallest
buckling load.
Well, we would now perform
a shift to the right,
subtracting mu K from this side,
from this side, and from
that side, to obtain this
eigenvalue problem.
That means we are really
shifting from here up to
there, and now we are interested
in solving kappa N
by operating on this
eigenproblems problem.
It is this eigenvalue problem
that we can operate on
directly, using the techniques
that I would be discussing
later, to determine search
method and the subspace
iteration method.
But before we get into those
techniques, I would like to
discuss with you some
preliminary considerations
that are important
when we look at
an eigenvalue solution.
The important first point that
I want to make is that there
is a traditional approach
for the solution of this
eigenvalue problem here.
Let's look at this eigenvalue
problem.
Where of course, when we're
talking about a buckling
analysis, we would have
different matrices here, but
basically, we still solve
this eigenvalue problem.
The traditional approach lies
in factorizing the M matrix
into Cholesky factors.
We talked about the Cholesky
factor when we talked about
solution of equations.
So here it comes up again.
We would factorize the M matrix
into Cholesky factors,
as shown here.
We define now a new eigenvector,
phi curl being
equal as shown here, L curl
transpose times 5.
We substitute from here into
there, and we directly obtain
this eigenvalue problem here.
Now we have the standard
eigenproblem.
Now once we have a standard
eigenproblem, there are a
large number of techniques
that can be used.
For example, the QR method,
the standard
Jacobi method, et cetera.
So this is, what
we might call.
a traditional approach to
solve the generalized
eigenproblem, this is the one
here that we are really
interested in.
But it involves this
transformation, and this
transformation here can involve
a very significant
cost, because we have to find
these Cholesky factors and
then, of course, we have to
calculate this K curl.
Another way of performing
a transformation of the
generalized item problem to a
standard form would be to
solve the eigenproblem
of M first.
W here and W transpose
[? store ?]
the eigenvectors of the M
matrix, and D squared is a
diagonal matrix of the
eigenvalues of M. And then
having factored M in this form,
an equation similar to
this one here can be written.
Where now, the transformation,
of course, involves the
eigenvectors, W.
Well, this approach is
sometimes still quite
effective, but in general, it
cannot be recommended because
there's too much cost involved
in the factorizing of the M
matrix, and then particular,
in the transformation here,
and the solution of this problem
and the, of course, to
get from this problem, the phi
vector, we have to go back to
this equation.
A direct solution of the
generalized eigenvalue problem
that we want to solve is
really more effective.
And now, we are ordering the
lambdas as shown here.
Remember, our smallest lambda
now is greater than 0, the
eigonvectors are stored as shown
here, and for most of a
position analysis, we are really
interested in solving
only for a certain number of
eigen pairs, i equals 1 to p,
as discussed in the last
lecture, or i equals r to s.
If we have a vibration
excitation problem, we really
only want to solve for specific
frequencies and
corresponding mode shapes
in a certain
interval, as shown here.
The solution procedures on this
generalized eigenvalue
problem can be categorized
into the following forms.
The first solution procedure,
or a whole class of solution
procedures, that I should really
say, which we might
call the vector iteration
techniques.
The idea is the following--
if we want to solve this
problem, then why not solve it
in the following way?
Start off with a vector on this
side, that we assume,
calculate a new vector on this
side, then take that new
vector, plug it back on the
right hand side, and cycle
through this way.
This is indeed inverse
iteration.
What do we do here?
We are putting a vector on the
right hand side, x1, when K is
equal to 1, that vector
we have to assume.
Then we are multiplying out
the right hand side.
Now we have a set of
simultaneous equations that we
would solve just in the same way
as we solve the equations
in static analysis.
We can think of this
as a load vector.
We are calculating this
displacement vector, and then
having got this displacement
vector, and not taking care of
this lambda, or having,
basically, taken this lambda
out of this equation.
Which means that this vector
will grow in lengths, or
collapse in lengths.
Therefore, want to scale this
vector down to a good length--
a length that does not hit
overflow, so to say, or
underflow in the machine.
And that scaling is achieved
as shown here.
So, the final result then, this
is just a scalar here, as
you can see, is a vector here,
which we can put on to the
right hand side and keep
on iterating around.
In fact, we find as that
iteration procedure converges
to the lowest eigenvector,
provided the starting vector
is not orthogonal, is not
M orthogonal to phi 1.
This is one first iteration
technique.
Maybe I should put
a side note down.
A side note that many of you
might have in your mind.
Many of you might have the
following question in your
mind-- why he iterate, why does
he not solve directly for
the eigenvalues?
Just like we saw a set of
simultaneous equations.
Well, there's one very important
point, and this is
the point--
if we are solving an eigenvalue
problem, and shown
here, then really that
means the following--
we are saying that determinant,
K minus lambda M
shall be equal to 0.
Why?
Because if we write
this equation in
the following form--
K minus lambda M times phi
equals 0, then we have here a
set of simultaneous equations
with a 0 vector on
the right hand side.
And there is an important
theorem in linear algebra that
says, only a solution to this
set of equations when this
coefficient matrix
is singular.
Which means that the
determinant of this
coefficient matrix must be 0.
So, what do we want?
We really want to solve p of
lambda determinant, K minus
lambda M. We want to solve for
the 0's of this polynomial.
That's really what we want.
Now, if we want to solve for
the 0's of this polynomial,
then we also have to understand
that when k is of
order 4, there will
be four 0's.
The polynomial itself
will be of order 4.
If K is of order, N, then
there will be N 0's.
So the polynomial is order N.
However, if we want to find
the solution of a polynomial,
or order N, then we very
quickly find that, in fact, we
can only look up the solution
to such polynomials if they are
of low enough order, lower
than say, 4.
Above for larger order
polynomials, there's no way
you can look up the solution.
You have to iterate to obtain
the solution of the 0's of
this polynomial.
However, since this problem
here, is completely equivalent
to this problem.
To solve this problem,
you have to iterate.
And this is the important
conclusion.
It is of up most importance that
you understand that to
solve an eigenvalue problem of
order larger than say, 4, you
will have to iterate.
Because you're solving for the
0's of a polynomial of order
larger than 4.
Only for very small order
polynomials, we can look up
the solutions in handbooks.
So having grasped the fact that
we have to iterate to
solve for the 0's of this
polynomial, to solve for the
eigenvalues of this problem, we
are stuck with iteration,
and since we're stuck with
iteration, we now want to come
up with techniques to iterate.
And the first technique to
iterate is this vector
iteration technique.
And the basic idea, once more,
is if you want to solve this
equation, well, then why not
iterate in the following way?
Put some starting value in here,
this number is just a
scalar, let's neglect that
effect for the moment.
And having put a starting value
in here, calculate this
one and keep on cycling
around this way.
And that's what we call
inverse iteration.
Inverse iteration here, a vector
inverse iteration,
because we have to solve a set
of equations here, with K as
the coefficient matrix.
There are other iteration
techniques.
There's also forward
iteration.
And basically, what we're
saying there is--
well if we are starting off here
and going around in this
circle, why not start off here
and go around in that circle,
the red line.
And that, in fact, gives
us forward iteration.
One can prove that that forward
iteration converges to
the largest eigenvalue.
We are usually interested in the
smallest frequencies, the
smallest eigenvalues, and
therefore, we are using
inverse iteration
quite commonly.
Then there is Rayleigh
Quotient iteration.
The Rayleigh Quotient iteration
is again, an inverse
iteration, however, with an
acceleration scheme in it, a
very effective acceleration
scheme.
This Rayleigh Quotient iteration
can be employed to
calculate one eigenvalue and
vector, and then, of course,
we have to deflate afterwards
the matrix, the coefficient
matrix for the eigenvector
that we have calculated
already, and we then could go on
towards the calculation of
additional eigenvalues
and vectors.
The same deflation also would
be used in inverse iteration
alone, and in forward
iteration alone.
In a Rayleigh Quotient
iteration, we converge to an
eigen pair, but which one
is not guaranteed.
So this is a class of
techniques, iteration methods
that we are using.
Another class of techniques,
again iteration methods, we
are stuck with iteration, as
I mentioned earlier, is the
polynomial iteration methods.
Here, we are saying that this
problem is equivalent to that,
we want to solve
for these 0's.
Therefore, for the 0's of this
polynomial, sketched out here,
and one way is to use
Newton iteration.
Here we have p, here
we have p prime.
Well, of course, if we have
p here, we have to also
recognize we should have
the coefficients here.
Well, these coefficients are
given here, A0 to a n.
And we could rewrite this
polynomial in this form, once
we know the zeroes.
Now, if we don't know the
zeroes, of course, we would be
stuck on iterating on this
matrix, where we would have to
calculate these coefficients.
However, there are now really,
two different techniques.
The first technique is explicit
polynomial iteration.
In the explicit polynomial
iteration, we expand the
polynomial and iterate for the
0's, by that I mean, we
actually expand this
polynomial.
However, this technique is not
suitable for larger problems
because first of all, there's
much work to obtain the ai's,
and then it's an unstable
process.
Unstable because small errors
in these coefficients here,
give large errors
in the zeroes.
So this is not a suitable
technique, and we are better
off using implicit polynomial
iteration.
In the implicit polynomial
iteration, we evaluate the
determinant all this
matrix here.
In others, p at mu i, via the L
D L transpose factorization,
which we discussed in the Gauss
elimination solution,
when we talked about Gauss
elimination solution.
To obtain the determinant of
this matrix here then, we need
simply to multiply all the
diagonal elements.
This technique is accurate,
provided we do not encounter
large multipliers L matrix.
And if we do, we have to
shift away, we have to
change our mu i.
Also we directly solve for
lambda 1 and so on.
And for the more we can use
effectively a secant
iteration, instead of
calculating, in other words,
the p prime at mu.
This is here approximately equal
to p prime, at mu i.
Instead of calculating this
derivative, we are putting
this value here, which gives
us an approximation to that
derivative, this is what we
call the secant iteration.
Once we have calculated one
eigenvalue, of course, we will
have to deflate to calculate the
next eigenvalue, and this
is the process that
he would pursue.
Pictorially, we have here,
our p lambda, this is the
polynomial.
Let me show it to you here.
Here, we have the polynomial,
here we have lambda 1, here we
have lambda 2.
In the secant iteration, we
start off with the value of mu
i minus 1 here, mu i, these
two values are given.
Usually, in a practical
analysis, mu 0 would be this
value here, and mu 1 would be
a lower bound on lambda 1.
And plugging these two values
in, we get mu i plus 1, and
you can see that this process
would then converge to this
eigenvalue.
Once we have lambda 1, we can
repeat the iteration.
However, working now on p
lambda divided by lambda
minus lambda 1.
And that means we are operating
on this polynomial
here, and polynomial then gives
us the iteration on that
polynomial then gives us
the second eigenvalue.
So we are deflating the actual p
lambda by the lambda 1 value
in order to obtain
a convergence
to the second value.
Well, this is the one
class of methods.
Another class of methods, the
third one, are the Sturm
sequence methods.
And here, the basic idea
is the following--
if we look at this eigenproblem,
and I use a 4x4
matrix here, then if we take a
shift on this eigenproblem, mu
S, and this is the shift here.
Then if we factorize K minus
mu S M, equal to L D L
transpose, again, we're using
our Gauss elimination
procedures basically.
Then the number of negative
elements in D is equal to the
number eigenvalues smaller
than mu S, a
very important point.
Let us look at this example
here of the 4x4 matrix.
Here we have plotted
characteristic polynomials.
The characteristic polynomial of
this 4x4 matrix, with that
M matrix, of course, is drawn
along here, four eigenvalues.
And I have put mu S here
as the red line.
What this theorem says is if I
factorize K minus mu S, M,
this being the K matrix, the
total K matrix, and the 4x4 M
matrix goes in here.
Then there would be one negative
element in D. One
only because mu S is large
than lambda 1.
If mu S were on this side
here, there would be two
negative elements in D. If mu
S were on this side, there
would be three negative
elements in D--
very important point because qw
can use this procedure to
directly calculate eigenvalues
the way I will be discussing
it just now.
However, let us look a little
bit more at why
this hole is here.
Well, it derives from the
associated constraint problems
with the original
eigenproblem.
The original eigenproblem
corresponds to this beam
problem, which we considered
earlier already in the
discussion of Gauss
elimination.
If I constrain this degree of
freedom here, I get a new
polynomial corresponding to
this problem, and the
important point is that the
lowest root, the lowest value
of this problem here lies in
between these two-- lambda 1
and lambda 2.
The second one here, lies
between lambda 2 and lambda 3,
and the third one here lies
between lambda 3 and lambda 4.
The second associated constraint
problem has two
eigenvalues, and this one lies
between these two, this one
lies between these two.
And the final eigenvalue
problem here, the third
associate constraint problem
obtained by knocking out these
degrees of freedom here, has one
eigenvalue, and that one
lies in between these
two values here.
It's this important fact
that is used to
derive this final result.
Now, we have not time to go
through the actual details,
but this is the important
fact here.
In other words, that the
[? i's ?] eigenvalue of this
associated constraint problem,
for example, the second
eigenvalue of this associated
constraint problem here,
bisects or lies in between,
not bisect--
lies in between lambda 2 and
lambda 3 of this eigenproblem
here, and so on.
That result is used to derive
this final result, which we
use effectively then in
the eigen solution.
And the class of techniques then
that we are referring to
using this fact are the Sturm
sequence methods.
So basically, what we are saying
is the following--
take this coefficient matrix,
now I make the mu x available.
We factorize that coefficient
matrix into L D L transposed,
and the number of negative
elements in D is equal to the
number of eigenvalues smaller
than mu S, I. How
do we use this fact?
Well, if this is here, the
polynomial, we could start off
by putting mu S 1 into this
point here, and we would find
out the number of eigenvalues
smaller than mu S 1.
Then we are taking, mu S 2, and
we find out the number of
eigenvalues smaller
than mu S 2.
Of course, we would find that
they are one more eigenvalue
smaller than mu S 2.
Then mu S 1, namely this one.
So we know there's one
eigenvalue in between mu S 1
and mu S 2.
Now we could bisect this
interval, and we would find
that, in fact, there is still
one more eigenvalue smaller
than mu S 3, then there was
smaller than mu S 1.
Because this eigenvalue
still lies on the left
side of mu S 3.
So we bisect again,
we get mu S 4.
Notice this distance here, is
equal to that distance here.
And now, we would find that the
eigenvalue still lies in
between these two lines, between
mu S 3 and mu S 4.
And like that. we could
continue bisecting the
interval until we finally find a
very small interval in which
this eigenvalue must lie.
We, of course, have to take care
in the L D L transpose
factorization, because we are
not working on a positive
definite matrix.
The multipliers must be small,
the L, I, J elements must
remain small in the
factorization.
But provided that is the case,
the round of errors are small,
and the procedure
is very stable.
However, convergence can be very
slow, can be extremely
slow because you have to cut
down the intervals further and
further until you finally get
a very small interval, in
which you now know the
eigenvalue does lie.
Of course, at some point, you
might want to switch to
another iteration scheme.
Once you know there is an
eigenvalue in between say mu S
3 and mu S 4, you might want
to switch to a iteration
scheme that converges to this
particular value much faster.
Finally, a whole class of
methods that I would like to
briefly mention to you are the
methods of transformations,
where we are operating on
this eigenvalue problem,
recognizing that phi transpose
K phi is equal to lambda.
And phi transpose M phi is
equal to I. Where phi is
defined as shown here, lambda
is defined as shown here.
This fact, of course, we use
already earlier in the
[? multiple ?]
position analysis.
Now how can we get
phi and lambda?
That is our objective.
Well, if we know that this
matrix diagonalizes the K
matrix, and it also diagonalizes
the M matrix,
then why not try to construct
it by iteration?
And this is the basic idea in
the transformation methods.
What we do is the following-- we
take the original K matrix,
we are operating with
P1 transpose K P1.
On K, and on M, such as to make
this resultant matrix
here closer to a
diagonal form.
Ultimately, we want to get
a diagonal matrix.
Well, one step in the iteration
is to make this P1
transpose K P1 matrix, and P1
transpose M P1 matrix, both of
these matrices a little closer
to diagonal form.
Then K and M were
by themselves.
So this is the first step.
Now, we have here, let's call
this a K2 matrix, and this
here an M2 matrix.
Now, we are operating with P2
transpose on K2, and also
there's a P2 here.
So let me take a different color
to show that now we are
operating with this part here,
and that part there.
And this, of course, we are
doing in such a way as to have
that P2 transposed, K2, P2
is a little bit closer to
diagonal form than was K2.
I hope you can see these
lines-- let me put
them in once more.
What I'm saying is we have K2
after having applied P1
transpose on P1, on K,
and similar for M.
And now we want to make K2 still
a little bit closer to
diagonal form.
Well, we are now applying P2
transposed on K2 and the P2 on
K2, this one here has been
replaced by K2, this one here
has been replaced by M2.
And what we're saying is that
this final result, in this
final result should be closer
to diagonal form.
In fact, this should be closer
to I matrix, and this should
be closer to the lambda
matrix, ideally.
Well, this is the basic process
that is used in the
generalized Jacobi method.
We can show that if
we choose specific
matrices, P I matrices.
That zero always one [? of ?]
diagonal element.
In other words, the P I matrix,
zeroes a particular
off diagonal element in this
current coefficient matrix,
similarly for the M2, for the
current M coefficient matrix.
Then we know in the generalized
Jacobi method that
the process finally converges.
It converges and we get a
diagonal matrix here.
With proper scaling, it will
be the identity matrix.
And here, we are getting also a
diagonal matrix, and if this
is an identity matrix, this will
actually be the matrix
storing the eigenvalues.
Well, this is the generalized
Jacobi method here.
They are other techniques that
can also be used, of course,
this is a very common approach
taken when we have M being
equal to the identity matrix.
However, the disadvantage of
this approach is that we are
calculating all eigen pairs
simultaneously.
In finite element analysis,
we are only interested in
specific eigenvalues, so lowest
P, or a certain number
of eigenvalues in an interval.
Here, we have to calculate all
of the eigenvalues stored in
the lambda matrix, and all
of the eigenvectors.
And the eigenvectors here, would
be these vectors here.
These are the the matrix phi,
which is P1 times P2, up to P
K, after K steps of iteration.
This gives us the matrix
phi, storing all of the
eigenvectors.
So the disadvantage is that we
are calculating all of that
eigenvectors, which in finite
element analysis is hardly
ever required.
All we want is the total number
of eigenvalues and
eigenvectors.
Remember, also if K
is of [? order ?]
1,000, this would be a
tremendous amount of work
involved and, in fact, it would
be beyond the current
state of computing capabilities
to use a
generalized Jacobi method on a
K matrix 1,000x1,000 and an M
matrix 1,000x1,000.
You will certainly stretch the
current computing capabilities
tremendously by using the
generalized Jacobi method on
large eigenproblems.
For large eigenproblems, it is
really best to combine the
basic approaches that
I just mentioned.
Let's recall the basic
approaches.
There were iteration methods,
vector iteration methods,
there were Sturm sequence
methods, there was the
transformation method.
And then, of course, there were
polynomial iteration methods.
So really, four classes
of methods that
we are talking about.
Each of them, we find,
have some advantages.
Well, as engineer, surely we
want to now combine the
advantages of each of these
methods to come up with
optimum techniques for our
specific problems.
Well, there are a number
of thoughts
that we would go through.
First of all, a determinant
search, a polynomial iteration
method would be effective
to get near a root.
Vector iteration then could
be used to calculate an
eigenvalue and an eigenvector.
The transformation method would
be good to orthogonalize
the current iteration vectors
if we iterate with more than
just one vector.
And the Sturm sequence method
is extremely powerful to
assure that we have actually
calculated the required
eigenvalues and eigenvectors.
Well, the first method then that
I would like to discuss
with you is the determinant
search method.
In this method, we have
combined some of these
techniques that I pointed
out to you earlier
in an optimum way.
Here, we have the polynomial P
lambda, we want to, of course,
solve for the roots of
that polynomial--
that is our objective.
Here is lambda 1, there
is lambda 2.
I also show a point,
A, because I will
refer to it just now.
The basic scheme in the
determinant search method is
to look for the zeroes of
the determinant, of the
determinant K minus mu I M. Of
course, these zeroes give us R
equal to the eigenvalues.
That's what we're interested
in calculating.
Well, we are calculating
the determinant by the
factorization of this matrix
into L D L transpose, and we
notice that this determinant is
simply the product of the
[? D I I's, ?] as I
mentioned earlier.
Now, having a certain starting
value, mu 0, say, and mu 1.
We can directly use the secant
iteration, that I mentioned to
you earlier to get close
to an eigenvalue.
Now, I also slipped in here
an acceleration factor.
This acceleration factor would
be equal to 1 in the normal
secant iteration that I showed
to you earlier already.
However, since we want to use
this polynomial iteration
technique only to get close to
an eigenvalue, and we might
actually obtain with eta equal
to 1, sometimes slow
convergence.
What we do is we simply
set it larger to
accelerate the process.
And this is what we're
doing here.
If we do jump beyond an
eigenvalue because we have
accelerated the secant
iteration.
In other words, if we do a jump
across here, then since
we are factorizing the matrix
here, we can also look at the
number of negative elements
in the D matrix.
These would tell us that we, in
fact, have jumped across an
unknown eigenvalue.
So, in this particular case, of
course, there would be one
negative element in
the D matrix.
And we would know now we
have jumped across.
The jumping across an unknown
eigenvalue is not possible
when eta is equal to 1.
However, it is possible when
eta is greater than 1.
And however, that jumping
does not hurt us.
In fact, all we will find is
that the Sturm sequence count
will tell us that we have jumped
across an eigenvalue,
and then, of course, we have to
go to another strategy of
solving for the eigenvalue
more accurately.
But the important point is that
all we want to do via
this procedure is to get into
the vicinity of the
eigenvalue.
We do not want to calculate it
accurately, all we want to do
is get into the vicinity of
an unknown eigenvalue.
First, of course, lambda 1,
then lambda 2, and so on.
There's also a concern, of
course, that we do not want to
jump beyond A, because if we, in
our process of looking for
lambda 1, we are jumping too
close to lambda 2, then via
the other solution techniques
that we are using later on
then to calculate the eigenvalue
more accurately, we
would actually converge
to lambda 2.
And, of course, that we
don't want, we want to
calculate lambda 1.
So, the process is then to start
off with eta equal to 1,
iterate, see how we are
progressing towards an unknown
eigenvalue.
If that progressing is
very slow, we are
choosing eta larger.
There are specific strategies
that we're using to choose the
right amount all eta.
And until we find that we are
close to an eigenvalue, either
from the left or we have jumped
across it already, but
you should never
jumped to far.
And we are making sure that we
never jump beyond that point
A. and having jumped, we find
that the Sturm sequence count
tells us about it.
And now, we are going on to
another strategy, and that
strategy is the vector
iteration, vector inverse
iteration method that I
discussed with you earlier.
What we are doing now, is we
have a new coefficient matrix,
that's the one.
We are sitting here, say, and
now I have assumed that we
have, in fact, jumped.
It's not necessary.
We might have also approached
from this side and come very
close to lambda J. And now, we
are using vector iteration to
get this eigenvalue
accurately.
This coefficient here,
or this value here
corresponds to that length.
And if you are adding this value
here to this shift, we
are getting an approximation
to lambda J. And that, of
course, is our objective.
Once we have lambda J, we have
calculated this eigenvalue--
the eigenvector comes out, in x
k plus 1 as k increases, so
we have calculated this eigen
pair, and now, of course, we
would use deflation method, just
the way I showed it to
your earlier, for the polynomial
iteration method.
To deflate the polynomial of
this value, implicitly--
implicitly, that's important--
and we would continue our
iteration process towards that
eigenvalue next.
In this process, we also want
to make sure that the
iteration vector is deflated
of the previously
eigenvectors, for example,
Gram-Schmidt
orthogonalization.
If the convergence is slow in
this particular iteration
here, we're using also the
really Rayleigh-quotient
iteration to speed up
iteration itself.
The advantage of the method--
well, it calculates only the
eigen pairs that are actually
required., there's no prior
transformation of the
eigenprobelm necessary.
The disadvantage of the method
is that we have to perform
many triangular factorizations.
Therefore, the method is really
only effective for
small banded systems.
If we want to calculate
eigenvalues of large banded
systems, we really need
an algorithm with less
factorizations, and more
vector iterations.
And that is the subspace
iteration method.
In fact, we have now extended
the subspace iteration method
to be also most effective for
small banded systems.
And I will just refer to
it very briefly later.
The basic steps of the subspace
iteration method are
the following.
Here, we have the first
equation used.
We have on the right
hand side, the
current iteration vectors.
Now, notice that in this
particular case, we're
iterating with q vectors,
where q ip larger than p
simultaneously.
This gives us here, q right
hand side vector.
We are solving for
q vectors here.
This is an inverse iteration
step on q vector
simultaneously.
Then we are calculating the
projections of these k and m
matrices on these vectors.
Notice that this pat here,
of course, is equal to
this right hand side.
So we would not calculate
this here.
We simply use the right hand
side, which we have evaluated
already and plug it
right in there.
But having calculated these two
matrices, which are now of
order q by q, we are solving
eigenvalue problem all of
these q by q matrices.
And the solution of
that eigenvalue
problem is shown here.
Notice this matrix here
is a q by q matrix.
We're using q vectors.
This is a q by q matrix storing
the eigenvectors of
this eigen problem here, of the
eigenproblem corresponding
to these matrices.
This here is the diagonal matrix
listing the eigenvalues
of the eigenproblem
corresponding to these matrices.
Having calculated these matrices
here, and of course,
that one too, we are performing
this operation to
get a new set of iteration
vectors, which then are
plugged back into here.
Notice that the solution of
this eigenproblem, q by q,
might be a 50x50 matrix here,
100x100 matrix, maybe a
200x200, but that already would
be a large number of
vectors if we're using--
a very large number
of vectors.
This solution of this
eigenproblem can be
effectively achieved via the
generalized Jacobi method,
which I referred to
briefly earlier.
Of course here, we are using
our solution algorithm for
static analysis.
There's L D L transpose
factorization involved here.
And here, this is a simple
matrix multiplication that has
to be carried out.
This part here, is the
eigenproblem solution, and
there's another vector
multiplication carried out here.
Now, under specific conditions,
this eigensolution
algorithm converges and the
vectors stored in x k plus 1,
they are q vectors now here,
with appropriate ordering,
converge to the phi matrix.
This is now an n by q matrix,
storing the lowest
eigenvectorr, or I should
say, the q eigenvectors
corresponding to the
lowest eigenvalues.
And here, we have it written
out, and of course, this is a
diagonal matrix.
The condition that we have to
satisfy here is that the
starting subspace spanned by
these vectors here must not be
orthogonal to the subspace
spanned by the p eigenvectors
that we are interested in.
Of course, here, I'm talking
about q eigenvectors.
I really am only interested in
p eigenvectors, in the lowest
p eigenvectors.
So in general, what happens is
that I will only be interested
in these eigenvectors here, and
the lowest eigenvalues.
One comes out here, I'm not
too much concerned about.
In fact, we are carrying these
along only to accelerate the
iteration scheme.
And I will show you just know
what the convergence rate is,
and why we are carrying
them along.
So since we only interested in
the lowest p eigenvalues and
corresponding eigenvectors,
we want to get convergence
towards those, and what that
means is that our starting
vectors in here must not be m
orthogonal to the eigenvectors
that we want to calculate,
phi 1 to phi p.
If that condition is satisfied,
one can show,
theoretically, and of course,
we see it in practice also,
that this iteration scheme will
always converge to the
lowest eigenvectors and
corresponding eigenvalues.
One important point here, once
we have calculated, say, a
certain number of iteration
vectors, and we have tested
for convergence, we are saying
that convergence is reached,
say, when the current iterates
on the eigenvalues don't
change very much anymore.
This tol might be 10 to the
minus 6, as an example.
Then once this condition is
satisfied, we stop the
iteration, and we really want
to make then sure that we
really converge to the
eigenvalues of interest.
And how is that accomplished?
Well, if these are the
p eigenvalues, we are
calculating error bounds on
these eigenvalues, indicated
here by the blue lines here.
And then just to the right
of the error bound.
Or we can really use that error
bound, we apply a Sturm
sequence shift, mu S. What this
then says that k minus mu
S factorize into L
D L transpose.
And we must now have in the D
matrix, p negative elements.
And only p, not more, not less,
just p negative elements
must be occurring
in the D matrix.
This check is absolutely sure.
If this check a satisfied, we
can be absolutely sure that we
have calculated the eigenvalues
of interest, the
lowest p eigenvalues, in
this particular case.
So I repeat, after we have
satisfied this convergence
rate, or this conversions
limit, I should say--
typically 10 to the minus
6, or 10 to the minus 8,
depending on what accuracy
you want.
We calculating eigenvalue
bounds, as shown here.
We are putting a mu S Sturm
sequence shift just to the
right of the last eigenvalue
bound, and if this is the p's
eigenvalue, we must have
here, exactly p
negative elements indeed.
The convergence rate of the
iteration, we find is given by
lambda i divided by
lambda q plus 1.
And the convergence rate to the
eigenvalues of interest
are just this value squared.
Notice that we have
here, q plus 1.
So if we are interested in the
p's eigenvalue,== the black
pen doesn't work too well, let
me take the blue one here--
if you're interested in the p's
eigenvalue as the largest
eigenvalue, notice that the
convergence rate is that
lambda p plus-- lambda p divided
by lambda q plus 1.
That is the worst convergence
rate that we are reaching
because the other eigenvalues
below lambda p are smaller,
giving us better convergence
rate.
So this is the worst that we
can reach, if we are only
interested in p eigenvalues
and corresponding
eigenvectors.
Notice however, that lambda
q plus 1 must be
greater than lambda p.
If lambda q plus 1 is
equal to lambda p,
we would never converge.
So this is the reason why we
are choosing q to be larger
than p, substantially
large than p.
For example, we might choose
q to be typically, as an
example, q being the maximum
of 2p and p plus 8.
This is a formula that
we have used with
quite a lot of success.
In other words, when p is equal
to 4, we would use--
no, sorry, I should say
the minimum here.
the In other words, when
p is equal to 4, we
would have 8 here.
When p is equal to
8, it's the same.
Because these two values
give us the same.
And when p is equal to 100,
then we just have 8 more.
Q is equal to 108.
This 8 here is a safeguard, so
that this cannot be equal to 1
in practice.
It would only be equal to 1 if
we would have, basically.
9 time the same root, and of
course, that is a case which
we would hardly encounter
in practice.
Now, regarding the choice
of the starting values.
For the vectors, there
are two choices.
x1 is simply a vector
with 1 only.
xj would be a vector with zeroes
everywhere, but with a
1 somewhere.
And that one is in
the j's entry--
sorry, the k's entry.
The k's entry for ek, ek has
in the case, entry of 1.
And otherwise, everywhere
zeroes.
This would be the second to
the q minus first vector.
And the last vector, we
take a random vector.
That is one choice of
starting vectors.
The Lanczos method can also be
used to generate starting
vectors very effectively.
Once we have selected the
starting vector, we go through
the iteration schemes the way
I have been displaying it.
And there, it is important, once
again, to perform after
the convergence- the Sturm
system sequence check, and
also we might want to calculate
error bounds on the
eigenvalues and eigenvectors.
These error bounds would be
calculated by simply saying,
well, if we want to satisfy--
or if we want to solve for
lambdas and phis that
satisfies this equation,
then why not see how
close we will satisfy.
Make that a minus and put here
an error, say, R, on
the right hand side.
Substituting then the last
values for lambda and phi that
we just kind calculated, the
last iterative values, we get
this top line here.
We're taking a norm
the way I've been
talking about earlier.
And we are also taking a norm
at the bottom to get,
basically, a relative value,
top to bottom.
And then relative value
gives us epsilon i.
So epsilon i should be of order,
10 to the minus 3, if
we want to have three-digit
accuracy in the eigenvalues
and eigenvectors.
In fact, the eigenvalues will
generally be more accurate
than the eigenvectors.
That is, of course, a
very low accuracy.
Ideally, we have much
more accuracy after
the iteration schemes.
We would have to tighten the
tolerance, the tol value that
I referred to earlier
sufficiently to make epsilon i
small enough.
Now, I like to refer, very
briefly also, to an
accelerated subspace iteration
method that we have been
developing during the last
years, which is a very
substantial extension of this
subspace iteration method.
The idea here is, basically,
that we wanted to combine the
sum of the effective techniques
that we are using
in the polynomial iteration
method, with the standard
subspace iteration method
that I have
discussed with you here.
Basically, in the accelerated
subspace iteration method, we
are not keeping a constant
coefficient matrix, as
we have done here.
The k matrix never changed.
Here, we are shifting the
coefficient matrix, we are
shifting through the spectrum.
Much in the same way as we are
pursuing it in the determined
search method.
And that is number one.
And number two-- we are also
not iterating with vectors
that are always larger than
the number of eigenvectors
that we want to calculated.
In fact, if we want to
calculate, say, 100
eigenvalues, we might just use
four iteration vectors at a
time, and shift through the
spectrum, always with four
iteration vectors, capturing
the eigenvalues values and
eigenvectors that we are really
interested in, in bundles.
So this is a way how we have
very substantially accelerated
the standard subspace iteration
method that I have
been talking to you
about just now.
If you are interested in seeing
some solution times,
please we look at
this reference.
Ladies and gentlemen, this
then brings me to the
conclusion of this lecture.
And in fact, it also brings us
to the conclusion of the whole
set of lectures that I have
been presenting to you.
These set up lectures have been
brief and very compact.
They've been a survey
introduction to the finite
element method--
a very brief and compact
introduction and survey.
Brief because there are
only 12 lectures.
Compact because I wanted to
present to you as much as
possible in these 12 lectures.
And there is, of course, a lot
of information that we could
have talked about.
However, I hope that the
information that I had given
in the lectures has been of
interest to you, and it will
also be valuable to you in your
work and general decision
making process of whether you
want to use a finite element
method, how you want to
use it, and so on.
I like to take the opportunity
at this point to thank the
Center of Advanced Engineering
Studies for the terrific
effort they've made in
preparing the tapes.
I'm very happy that they have
been cooperative with me in
the way they did, in the
preparation of the tapes.
I also would like to thank you
as listeners for your patience
of listening to the tapes and,
once again, I hope you found
the tapes interesting and
have obtained some value
information on them.
Best of luck in your further
studies of the
finite element method.